the town of Busey lies at the mouth of
the pool a river when cyclone Addai tore
through here in March floodwaters from
the entire region flowed into the river
the pond wave burst its banks flooding
the surrounding countryside houses were
washed away including that of Farmer
Brown Filipe his entire harvest was
wiped out - before the cyclone K might
be making good progress but when it hit
it literally threw me back to square one
I'm now starting from the bottom again
point zero things would have been even
worse if it weren't for the Gorongosa
National Park this unique wetland
landscape lies 140 kilometres up River
like a sponge the vegetation and the
network of streams and rivers they're
absorbed huge amounts of water dumped by
the cyclone mark Stallman's the chief
ecologist at the park checks the water
levels regularly he says even today five
months after the cyclone the flood
waters are still draining out of the
landscape and into the pond way River
impact landscapes can play a
tremendously positive buffering effect
they generally kind of attenuate the
extremes of weather the extremes of wind
and extremes of water and that's why we
need those those big landscapes they
also serve as a reservoir they are
hosting biodiversity they are hosting
systems that are effective that are
functioning but this natural paradise is
under threat on nearby Mount Gorongosa
residents have cleared huge swaths of
forest for farmland forests have a key
regulatory function absorbing and
releasing water it was clear that if the
deforestation continued many of the
springs that sustain the wetlands would
disappear so six years ago the park
administration came up with an idea
instead of subsistence farming residents
could help restore the forest by
planting coffee along with hardwood
trees
to provide shade for the crops to thrive
project manager seon-ah Milani shows us
a plantation with 250,000 young coffee
plants and hardwood saplings for there
were almost no trees left here at all
the whole place was totally exposed to
the Sun now with the coffee and the
trees we have two layers of shade
Gorongosa coffee is already a success
story more than 400 farmers are now
growing the new crop that's nearly half
the families in the region
the park administration buys up the
harvest at a guaranteed price those who
are looking for an additional income can
help with the processing of the beans
the projects is succeeding despite
difficult conditions
Mozambique Civil War officially ended in
1992 but there have been flare-ups at
times between government troops and
rebel forces we had some problems in
2015 and had to stop work because of the
conflict but now everything's quiet and
we can get on with our work we're seeing
that it is possible to produce coffee on
Mount Gorongosa the community has
embraced the idea they're producing
coffee replanting trees taking care of
the forest and helping the environment
the coffee beans are taken to the town
of Gorongosa for roasting and packing
while we're there the local mare drops
in to visit the center he's hopeful that
the coffee will not only protect the
environment but also helped to promote
reconciliation fighters loyal to the
rebel group run amo were long holed up
in the hills and forced some farmers to
join their ranks as a result there are
townspeople who are wary of the farmers
this project is a good thing it creates
ties between the coffee growers on the
mountain and the processing plant here
in town we're not affected by any
conflict because the coffee farmers
haven't been involved in the fighting
this project improves relations between
people
town and people up in the hills Russia
keeper system shown up here on my street
Alakazam since the start of the project
farmers have planted more than a hundred
and forty hectares of coffee and 50,000
hardwood trees all the trees are native
to Mozambique the plan is to add another
hundred and fifty Hector's next year if
deforestation can be halted or reversed
the wetlands of Gorongosa National Park
will be preserved forests protect the
park which in turn helps to protect
people living in coastal areas as
climate change continues well
functioning ecosystems will become more
important than ever
Abril Felipe has experienced many
cyclones before but he's noticed a
change in recent years
gosh what seems to be getting worse year
by yea cyclone in floods we had last
year reached the porch of my house de
quoi cyclone this year reached my
windows things are getting worse sister
daughter but Abril Felipe has no plans
to give up he's building a new house
where his old one once stood he'll
replace the mud walls with stones once
he has the money
maybe nature will spare him next time if
not he's hoping the National Park will
protect him from the worst
you